In this problem, we're given a
collection of 10 variables, x1
through x10, where each i, xi,
is a uniform random variable
between 0 and 1.
So each i is uniform between 0
and 1, and all 10 variables
are independent.
And we'd like to develop a bound
on the probability that
some of the 10 variables, 1 to
10, being greater than 7 using
different methods.
So in part A we'll be using
the Markov's inequality
written here.
That is, if we have a random
variable, positive random
variable x, the probability x is
greater than a, where a is
again some positive number, is
bounded above by the expected
value of x divided by a.
And let's see how that works
out in our situation.
In our situation, we will call
x the summation of i equal to
1 to 10xi, and therefore, E of
x is simply 10 times E of x1,
the individual ones, and
this gives us 5.
Here we use used the linearity
of expectation such that the
expectation of the sum of the
random variable is simply the
sum of the expectations.
Now, we can invoke Markov's
Inequality.
It says x greater
or equal to 7.
This is less than E of x over 7,
and this gives us 5 over 7.
For part B, let's see if we can
improve the bound we got
in part A using the Chebyshev
inequality, which takes into
account the variance of
random variable x.
Again, to refresh you on this,
the Chebyshev Inequality says
the probability that x deviates
from its mean E of x,
by more than a is bound above
by the variance of x divided
by a squared.
So we have to actually do some
work to transform the
probability we're interested
in, which is x greater or
equal to 7, into the form that's
convenient to use using
the Chebyshev Inequality.
To do so, we'll rewrite this
probability as the probability
of x minus 5 greater or equal
to 2 simply by moving 5 from
the right to the left.
The reason we chose 5 is because
5 is equal to the
expected value of x from part
A as we know before.
And in fact, this quantity is
also equal to the probability
that x minus 5 less or
equal to negative 2.
To see why this is true, recall
that x is simply the
summation of the xi's, the 10
xi's, and each xi is a uniform
random variable between
0 and 1.
And therefore, each xi, the
distribution of which is
symmetric around its mean 1/2.
So we can see that after we
add up all the xi's, the
resulting distribution
x is also symmetric
around its mean 5.
And as a result, the probability
of x minus 5
greater than 2 is now equal to
the probability that x minus 5
less than negative 2.
And knowing these two, we can
then say they're both equal to
1/2 the probability x minus 5
absolute value greater or
equal to 2, because this term
right here is simply the sum
of both terms here and here.
At this point, we have
transformed the probability of
x greater or equal to 7 into the
form right here, such that
we can apply the Chebyshev's
Inequality basically directly.
And we'll write the probably
here being less than or equal
to 1/2 times, applying the
Chebyshev Inequality, variance
of x divided by 2 squared.
Now, 2 is the same as a
right here, and this
gives us 1/8 times--
now, the variance of x, we know
is 10 times the variance
of a uniform random variable
between 0 and 1, which is
1/12, and that gives us 5/48.
Now, let's compare this with
the number we got earlier
using the Markov Inequality,
which was 5/7.
We see that 5/48 is much
smaller, and this tells us
that, at least for this example,
using the Chebyshev
Inequality combined with the
information of the variance of
x, we're able to get a stronger
upper bound on the
probability of the event that
we're interested in.
Now, in part B, we saw that
by using the additional
information of the variance
combined with the Chebyshev
Inequality, we can improve upon
bound given by Markov's
Inequality.
Now, in part C, we'll use
a somewhat more powerful
approach in addition to the
Chebyshev Inequality, the
so-called central
limit theorem.
Let's see if we can even
get a better bound.
To remind you what a central
limit theorem is, let's say we
have a summation of i equal
to 1 to some number n of
independent and identically
distributed
random variables xi.
Now, the central limit theorem
says the following.
We take the sum right here, and
subtract out its means,
which is E of the same
summation, and further, we'll
divide out, what we call
normalize, by the standard
deviation of the summation.
In other words, the square
root of the variance
of the sum of xi.
So if we perform this procedure
right here, then as
the number of terms in the sums
going to infinity, here
as in goes to infinity, we will
actually see that this
random variable will converge
in distribution in some way
that will eventually look like
a standard normal random
variable with means 0 and 1.
And since we know how the
distribution of a standard
normal looks like, we can go to
table and look up certain
properties of the resulting
distribution.
So that is a plan to do.
So right now, we have
about 10 variables.
It's not that many compared to
a huge numbering, but again,
if we believe it's a good
approximation, we can get some
information out of it by using
the central limit theorem.
So we are interesting knowing
that probability summation of
i equal to 1 to 10 x1 greater
or equal to 7.
We'll rewrite this as 1 minus
the probability the summation
i equal to 1 to 10, and
xi less equal to 7.
Now, we're going to apply
the scaling to the
summation right here.
So this is equal to 1 minus the
probability summation i
equal to 1 to 10xi minus 5.
Because we know from previous
parts that 5 is the expected
value of the sum right
here, and divided by
square root of 10/12.
Again, earlier we know that
10/12 is the variance of the
sum of xi's.
And we'll do the same on the
other side, writing it 7 minus
5 divided by square
root of 10/12.
Now, if we compute out the
quantity right here, we know
that this quantity is roughly
2.19, and by the central limit
theorem, if we believe 10 is a
large enough number, then this
will be roughly equal to 1 minus
the CDF of a standard
normal evaluated at 2.19.
And we could look up the number
in the table, and this
gives us number roughly,
0.014.
Now let's do a quick summary of
what this problem is about.
We're asked to compute the
probability of x greater or
equal to 7, where x is the sum
of 10 uniform random variables
between 0 and 1, so
we'll call it xi.
We know that because each
random variable has
expectation 1/2, adding 10
of them up, gives us
expectation of 5.
So this is essentially asking,
what is the chance that x is
more than two away from
its expectation?
So if this is a real line, and
5 is here, maybe x has some
distribution around 5, so the
center what the expected value
is at 5, we wonder how likely is
it for us to see something
greater than 7?
Now, let's see where do we land
on the probably spectrum
from 0 to 1.
Well, without using any
information, we know the
probability cannot be greater
than 1, so a trivial upper
bound for the probability
right here will be 1.
Well, for the first part we use
Markov's Inequality and
that gives us some number, which
is roughly equal to 0.7.
In fact, we got number 5/7,
and this is from Markov's
Inequality.
Oh, it's better than 1, already
telling us it cannot
be between 0.7 and 1, but
can we do better?
Well, the part B, we see that
all the way, using the
additional information variance,
we can get this
number down to 5/48, which
is roughly 0.1.
Already, that's much
better than 0.7.
Can we even do better?
And this is the Chebyshev,
and it turns out we
can indeed do better.
Using the central limit theorem,
we can squeeze this
number all the way down to
0.014, almost a 10 times
improvement over the
previous number.
This is from central
limit theorem.
As we can see, by using
different bounding techniques,
we can progressively improve the
bound on the probability
of x exceeding 7, and from this
problem we learned that
even with 10 variables, the
truth is more like this, which
says that the distribution of
x concentrates very heavily
around 5, and hence, the
probability of x being greater
or equal to 7 could be much
smaller than one might expect.